alors on regarde sur les images puisque
on commente en direct je vous redonne la
parole tout à l'heure brigitte macron
qui sort de la voiture qui saluait la
foule on voit que plusieurs dizaines de
badauds se sont massés devant le palais
de l'elysée
voilà l arrivée de l'épousé du chef de
l'état élu
brigitte macron qui on le disait il ya
quelques minutes à elsa sera accueillie
par l'épousé de jean pierre jouyet
brigitte taittinger juillet puisque il
n'y a pas actuellement de première dame
à l'elysée c'est donc avec la femme de
jean pierre juillet que s'entretiendra
brigitte macron pendant que son époux et
françois hollande s'entretiennent dans
le bureau présidentiel
en fait sûrs en quelque sorte 3 tête à
tête ce matin il y aura le tête à tête
entre le président élu et le président
sortant dans le bureau du chef de l'état
au premier étage de l'elysée qu'on
appelle le salon doré il y aura
effectivement un autre tête à tête entre
brigitte macro et brigitte juillet comme
il y avait eu d'ailleurs en 2012 un tête
à tête entre entre carla bruni sarkozy
cécilia sarkozy à l'époque en 2002 et il
y aura un troisième donc tête à tête
entre jean pierre juillet le secrétaire
général sortant de l'elysée est celui
qui sera le secrétaire général de
l'elysée pour emmanuel macron qui
s'appelle alexis colère qui était son
directeur de cabinet à bercy